Doesn't look like anyone's there anyway, Alex.
Hello? Anyone here?
Is Amal not on?
No one's been on since I've joined.
I see.
Okay, maybe.
Maybe he wasn't on either, I don't know.
I don't know either.
I mean, I didn't log on until like 7 after or something like that, but I think he would have messaged us.
I might.
Probably.
Mm.
Oh, so you just took lunch. Okay.
Ohh.
After 10 minutes.
All right.
So...
Uhh...
Okay.
A quick thumbs up on that, and...
Mhm.
Just go on, just go on mute, Karen, and camera off. Okay. And then I can continue my conversation with you.
Okay.
Bigger, hey Alex.
Hello!
Hey, I'm sorry, waited for a few minutes, then I thought maybe I saw Aleks was away showing on the team, so I stepped up for lunch.
No, that's fine. I, Alex and I were talking and I interrupted him and said, you know, we're supposed to be on a call. He's like, oh, that's so rude. I'm so sorry. So we got on. And then you were not there.
Yeah.
Pre.
Yeah, I thought maybe when I checked on the team, then I saw when you appear away, so I thought you may be busy somewhere or stuck. Anyway, how are you doing, Aleks, Karen?
Yeah, good, good. Sorry, yeah, I did not know that. Yeah, my bad. I doing good. Just need somebody following me around and getting me getting me where I need to go.
Hey, no.
Um...
Today is the meeting day, so I had a, you know, we had a long meeting with the team this morning. You probably saw we were talking for a long time. Summer, you know, Summer and Vincent and Shivani, you know, all along the line, you know, Animesh and he departed, but
Yeah.
You know, it's good, it's good.
You know, good, good. We had a good meeting. And I think, you know, Sameer is definitely the kind of person I like to have on board. He is very, very technically skilled. And it's a very, very good thing because it's going to allow us to get the momentum we need in the right direction.
No, no, no, that's right. We agreed with the way he, he was very excited, you know, to work and I mean I was checking with him this morning, so I have a schedule to connect with him daily. So I was asking how the training everything is going. He said, like, oh, and I have already started working on the ticket. That's how he is the excitement, you know.
Yeah, I mean, the training is minimal. He doesn't need a lot of training. He has a very good handle on, certainly from a standpoint of, you know, the areas I'm asking to work in infrastructure, it's less of a customer, less customer facing today. You know, he doesn't need to
Right, yeah.
Yeah, not that many phone calls with customers. So he's able to work directly in the infrastructure. He knows where to very quickly understood where to go to get information, you know, how to understand the way we document things. He understood it almost immediately, you know, and had no issues. You know, he was very complimentary too. He said, you know, he's seen a very
Yeah.
organized. He says that we're very organized. We have a lot of our, you know, good security practices. So, you know, and so, you know, it's just just great, great to have him on the team. I think he's really going to help on Amit just the whole the whole dynamic is is is good.
Bye.
in that sense.
You know, I think about the ConnectWise Access we talked about, you know, that's still in the back of my mind. I have so many little projects, that's one project, but I have to really slow take a slow look at that type of thing regarding access controls and permissions and things like that. But
You know, it just takes takes time for me to, every week goes by, every day goes by, and you know, all the different work that I'm doing. So, we hired, we hired somebody 2 weeks ago, then we had, you know, Summer joined us last week. So, every time I bring somebody on board, it also takes, you know, a couple of days to...
Number.
to get adjusted with that.
No, no, that that really makes sense. That's why I did not ping you or message you or anything. I came to know that, you know, the other person is onboarded, somebody is onboarded. So you're probably busy on that side.
Yeah, and then we're hopefully going to be onboarding, you know, a sales account rep as well. You know, I have to still interview for those roles, the full-time account rep, which will work in complement with Karen in a lot of ways in a complementary role.
Kip.
Yeah.
Play.
About the building these little teams within teams, you know, in the organization, and you know, trying to scale. I, like I talked to with Ronald this morning, you know, it's you know, building a team takes time, so it just takes time building a good team.
I.
Um...
In terms of, you know, we don't need to review anybody in particular. You know, there's so many good things heading in the right direction with with with even with on a mesh, even though we may not be where we want to be with.
Be.
like the dashboards and reporting and a deep, you know, like an understanding as to 100% what I want from outcomes, you know, the reports being generated from Veeam Service Provider Console is ultimately, you know, and I still find that the backups are not.
He doesn't catch them all. He doesn't, he doesn't catch them. You know, I mean, we have, we have the service provider console and we have, you know, Veeam One. Those are supposed to be tools that help him to very quickly be able to determine if there's a failure.
Mm.
and what failures need to be looked at from a console, from a single pane of glass. But, you know, I find that...
You know, he has had some issues, you know, noticing, you know, some backup failures, which are not that hard because we don't have that many, we really don't have that many instances. So I said to him a few days ago, probably a week ago, I said, no matter what your tools are, your responsibility is to make sure that we have good backups.
You know, um, so...
But he's getting there. I think, I think it just, you know, he's getting there. He has some natural talent, you know, he does have some natural skill and talent. So, you know, that that comes, that also comes through. Like I could see that when he's sending some ticket updates, some that
Yeah.
may or may not be AI, you know, assisted, but some of them are genuinely like, that's the only problem with AI, right? Is when AI writes the entry, you know, is it the tech or is it AI that, you know, understands it is the question. And, you know, so I think there has been,
I have to cut through and try to make sure I understand that he understands what he's doing, you know, and what he's working on. And it's not just an AI type of generated response or that.
you know, he needs to natively understand the product more than, let's say, always have to go to Claude or always have to go to, you know, call Veeam tech support. He needs to natively be a good Veeam administrator. He needs to natively, just like Summer does. Summer knows things natively, like he just knows.
Yeah.
So, he'll handle a lot of things because he knows, you know, he's technically skilled in those areas, so he'll he'll be able to handle, you know, these things. So, we need we need we need Anamesh to come up to that level where you know he's the Veeam administrator, you know, to truly understands, you know, the product. So, we're getting there, but...
Um, that's the that's the big focus right now for on mesh.
Yeah, I'm also keeping close eye on Amit because I have asked the dedicated person who come on the day shift, who is good at VM side. I mean, so I have asked him if any support that he needed, he can reach out to me, but yeah, but immediate his, you know, connect would be on that person so he can help, immediate help. And I think.
Yeah, I want to share the other important update. You know, like Shivani is in a different location, Chandigarh.
Yes.
So I think it's probably the good part that her parents is moving to the Noida location. So she's moving together with them and the same location here. The benefit will be all the engineers will be going to the same place. I have decided to dedicate a space for all, all the four separate.
Oh, really? Okay.
That's crazy!
no disturbance from other engineer, partner, client. They're going to be sitting on other corner of the specific dedicated for the APMIT and all they're going to together. So I think dates are going to move July 6th that she has already planned the accommodation and everything. So the HR process has been completed, everything.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
So she's going to be transitioning everything from Chandigarh to here. Things are good part to be at all are together working in one place, one leadership under here. So because I have to call her, connect, you know, sometime it's not that much easy where you call, she's on a busy call working on tickets, but when they are.
Mhm.
near to me, I can go anytime, sit next to them, check everything, whatever they are doing.
OKOK, that sounds that sounds great.
P.
Glad to hear that. You know, hopefully, you know, after we bring on a sales account manager, you know, hopefully we start to acquire some more accounts and then hopefully we can start to hire more engineers in Noida. And then the team will grow maybe from 4 to 6 to, you know, and then
Yeah.
and that type of thing, keep adding on.
No, yeah, that's about that. I know you have another conversation going, I think, with Ankur and all the workstation ongoing things right, so Rick was, yeah.
Cancelled the hardware order, because you know, 'cause I, it was just weird, and so yeah, and so I canceled that.
Yeah, I saw the email.
And I got confirmation from Ronald that it's canceled. Now, I did also in that email, you saw what I said, that I'm going to circle back and come back. And I think what I will do, and I didn't want to bring it up this week because I just want to sort of let everything settle down a little bit. But
Um...
We'll probably want to just switch everybody to laptops.
And it provides more flexibility. So we'll just, and then what's nice about that, and I'll just send a very nice, like simple email, say, this is what we not want, this is what we need. Tell me if there's any cost. That's it. You know, that way it's nice and simple. And then they get back to me, tell me the price and we're done. I know, you know, no, no, no back and forth and confusion.
Yeah, sure, yeah.
And it's, you know, and what happens is then actually you guys end up getting a very powerful workstation back, which you guys can use for something else. It's actually a lot cheaper for the laptop to be used for you than it is the powerful workstations that we have in place, which right now, the ones that we have,
The.
Anamesh and Vincent are using are very expensive workstations.
I get it, yeah. So I think the reason probably the laptop that Sameer has assigned, that was just temporary from the IT, so I will probably have to update to make sure that's going to be permanent, his device that he's going to use. So as of now, they have two devices, one which is their own ITBD laptop that they use for ITBD internal.
Mhm.
Purpose, so just access their HR portal, et cetera, and just so another one, of course, your side, so that was provided in my.
So Summer, Summer has two laptops.
Yes, one is the ITBD, where he can access his pay sleep, et cetera, chat portal, mark his attendance, anything related to ITBD. Any other one, which we provided him a temporary to thinking we're going to get the workstation on the desktop. So that was on a temporary basis. So if you are going to stick with the laptop only for all that, I think I will.
Okay.
Mhm.
put forward a request to the internal ITBD so they can permanently assign that laptop to summer if that is planned.
Okay.
Okay, because he's, he and on a mesh too, like what happens is these guys and Vincent will too, is like, you know, they're able to jump in if something comes up, you know, with the laptop, if they need to remotely when they're out of the office. So that has been already very important with summer.
Yeah.
already, you know, and that's exactly what we, you know, that's how IT works. So that works out well.
No, no, of course.
I think, because last last week I think there was a big heavy storm here, right? So people were getting delayed to the office, you know, a lot of rain here, so thinking that some criteria would be to do allow to the people to just, you know, maybe work from home rather, you know, spending half an hour hours on the road, right?
Mhm.
Yeah.
So, but in such, yeah, if they have a laptop, they can log in in desktop, they have to come office, so...
Right. Yeah. And.
There, there.
But does Shivani have two laptops? Because I...
So 2 laptop is only because normally because of course they are busy most of the time in the regular your APMIT site, right? So only we take some exception for them because as for the policy we allow only them one laptop. So if that is the criteria, so we.
they follow, right? Because only few limited things they access on the ITBD side that may rest like a 30 minute, half an hour, they access that laptop, rest 7, 8 hour, no use of that laptop.
So you're saying, because I, you know, at first you said that everyone gets 22 laptops, but are you saying some people get 2 laptops, some people don't?
No, so normally we provide one for everyone, right? But here in your case, because you are managing the device, right? So they cannot access anything related to ITBD. So where they return the laptop which they are using and like Sameer has the different laptop altogether.
Uh-huh.
I see.
Okay. Okay. All right. That makes sense. That's fine.
So, I'll make a note of, so they're gonna use the laptop, right? No, no more desktop.
So...
As of summer, summer for as of now.
Well, it's just, yeah, it's just summer, yeah, right as of now. I have to send an official request, I think. Basically, like, do Animesh and Vincent, do they have a laptop, an ITBD laptop?
No, so I think, no, they don't. They have, they have the when the joined IPM ITBD, but they return to the IT department because the config and everything is not that much what Sameer has. So those are specific device that we need to give them because normally they get less config laptop, the regular engineer.
Vincent, probably.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Right.
Okay, so.
Yeah, I mean, those desktops are so nice that the Animash and Vincent have. They're really, really good, but...
Yeah, yeah.
You know, and, and yeah, I mean, and it's fine that they they don't have a laptop now, and if they, but if we did a laptop, then yeah, that could still be their only device, so you have one device, but it would still be APM IT managed. You guys still have your enable agent on even, you know, the ones that we manage anyway, so...
Yeah.
Yeah, only I think they don't access anything on the ITBD side, just maybe log into their attendance portal, check their pay slip, but that's it only. And maybe log in for the ITBD team. So maybe two, three things that they access only the laptop.
No.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah. Okay.
Which I think you don't, there should be no issue to accessing on your side too, if they log in on their portal, yeah.
Okay.
So, I actually have a meeting with Vincent now.
Uh, we good? Can we can we drop off the meeting, or are we is there anything?
Yeah, I think we're good. Yeah, any to do that think you think that's pending from, I know the other conversation is was there, but anything from my side, a service delivery point of view which you think, I know an MS is on my top priority, but anything that you think I need to focus and work closely with the rest of the engineer?
Kour.
Yeah, I think Summer, the first thing I noticed is that he has a tendency not to update tickets. So, you know, it's something a habit he'll have to learn to make sure that he's, you know, keeping tickets up to date and time and scheduling and things like that. Shivani slipped as well, like Shivani continues to slip regarding.
In the real-time.
you know, updates, real time updates, it becomes a very important when it's customer issue that's being reported. You know, the ticket has changed from assigned to in progress and that there's actual updates going inside the ticket, not just like, you know, I checked the ticket 2 hours later and then she says it's solved or that it's, you know, and it's not in the ticket. It's just something I, you know, so I ask her and she says, oh,
I talked to them and said, well, where's the notes and the ticket and where's the customer, you know, communication? So they typed out, typing messages to customers. I stressed it during our meeting today with the team as being very, very important to make sure we're communicating with our customers and updating tickets in real time, updating your calendar and time entries.
updating the internal notes of the tickets so that we know the technical issues that are related to it. And then you escalate it, you know, you know, if you need to, like Shivani needs to take, do some initial, you know, troubleshooting, initial documentation of the problem. And then if she needs to escalate to Summer or Vincent,
that should be documented in the ticket. That's one of the negative things about everybody working in one building, because if they're all in the one building, they fall out those processes. They don't, they may not follow the processes, right? Because they're going to look over and say, hey, you know, can you do this? But it's not in the ticket, you know?
Ohh, yeah.
So it has to be in the ticket. And so that when anybody, the customer is up to date, like we all have the update at the same time, the customer gets an update, the texts get an update, that type of thing. So that's the only thing I stress this week, and you can maybe continue to.
Sure, I will connect with them.
continue to, you know, make sure that, you know, just so you're aware of what I was talking to them about this week.
No, no, no, definitely. I will connect with them to make sure it goes a little bit to make sure they put on the ticket in progress, update note on real-time basis, either not on hours or two hours later. Yeah, and rest we're only connecting on team. If you find anything immediately that need my attention, feel free to reach out. I'm available all the time.
Yeah.
Alright, Aman, appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you, Gary. Thank you. Take care. Have a good day. Bye.
OK, yep, hi.
Alright, I'll see ya. You too. Bye-bye.